The fundamental design goal of the internet
was multiplexed utilization of existing interconnected networks.
There are two important aspects to this
goal. One is multiplexing or sharing. So one
of the fundamental challenges that the internet
technologies needed to solve was the shared
use of a single communications channel. The
second major part of this fundamental goal is
the interconnection of existing networks. These
two subproblems had two very important solutions.
Statistical multiplexing or packet switching was
invented to solve the sharing problem. And,
the narrow waist was designed to
solve the problem of interconnecting networks. Let's
talk about each of these now. In turn. We'll first talk about packet switching